hello mate that's me what's your name
buddy I'm Maryann also what you're from
oh yeah
why'd you call me we're making a
documentary about property my property
yeah I thought about you broadly about
Hupa tribe is live we could do another
one on that so we basically come to
London with no money are trying to buy a
house with no money
well we're believers man we haven't done
it yet in London but we have done it in
other places where Sheffield Sheffield
yeah
bubbly no my wife is the barber in there
yeah the Bible is a crazy place at the
moment yeah it's much cheaper
yeah are you gonna get a few ways first
way is we could rent a property off a
landlord and then we could then rent it
out on a room-by-room basis yeah but
that's council potentially if it depends
on how big how big it is four bedrooms
they say if it's you'll need a license
but the landlord will often get the
license for you
listen to let it out yeah which cost
money I guess because 24 the landlord
but not for me
grabbin distance the house got a noise
pensive annual the rent you meant
yeah well that's that I guess the goal
is to agree a small guaranteed rent for
the landlord so he has no hassle and he
can just move on with his life animals
we need to mean that the house he also
needs what to maintain the house no I
will then maintain and manage the house
I'll become like the owner are you gonna
make up or make money because I'll rent
it out on the room-by-room basis exactly
but still you got to feel that range
yeah things in the house yeah I don't
but if I'm paying the rent say two
thousand pound to the landlord but then
I'm renting out for two thousand three
thousand four thousand a cone
that's true space I don't think that it
is but it's about finding the right
house you found the right house and the
right landlord and you're putting the
right negotiations okay so if that
happened
yep so ethically how long is gonna last
to dink before London is gonna raise the
rent so you have a management contract
in place on you no no it can be for
three years or even five years all right
and you've got a Mick profit from there
yep one tells on you squint one past
each month will be very good minimum of
500 pounds thousand pound on a good
month and then if you get two or three
of those then that's an average salary
replaced and that's just one strategy
but there's several strategies that I'm
thinking okay do you like that one man
yeah would you do it well I'm I'm
thinking about it since they came here
really that's I thought you and your
questions were quite on point is another
strategy buy a house now but agree to
pay for it later
but I mean to pay for it later
yeah back nope with the owner so you say
to the owner the house is worth four
hundred thousand I'll give you five
hundred thousand in seven years and then
in the meantime I'll pay you a small
monthly wait take up I'll take on your
mortgage and then you can just move on
no his mortgage payments might be small
and you're making a small profit but
then in seven years you have the option
to buy the house you either pay the rent
or you a mortgage yeah yeah and then in
seven years
hopefully the property will be worth a
lot more and then you'll have a fixed
price to buy it you like you like that
one yeah that's good it's got a lease
option agreement another one is to just
find out find a house knock it down and
knock it down in price and then find an
investor and charge a broker fee turn of
the words you're an investor you've got
money and you're looking for a good deal
I go and I negotiate and find a good
deal and then I say to you hey I've got
this property these are the figures if
you want it you need to pay me five
thousand pounds so you're gonna get
improperly from the Commission yes just
to like a one-off but then you can do
that a few times save that money and
then you can put that down into your own
business you working for the price of
the home yep get commission from the
investor yep and I'll give you one more
buy a house below market value that's in
the horrible state
borrow the money from the bank to buy
the house borrow the money from the bank
to do the refurb on a buy to let
mortgage which then pays off the loan
and you've lifted the value to the house
and you sell it now then you just rent
it out down it's like buying a house for
free but you obviously need the bank's
money to begin with yeah yeah but that's
what we're trying to do in London
you have to wish us luck I have a ship
huge way you think it's possible they're
here about the Ranger Alex yes the first
example yeah taken
it's a bit harder yeah but possible but
possible yeah then also have a crazy
score only for some of them no you
weren't you don't need to be critical
for all of those strategies really just
for the last one but even if you haven't
got a good credit score you can still
find someone who has and they can be
your host
yeah but we're all counting on someone
else right now cuz you're driving this
car for me yeah but then providing
services yes and you're sure so you're
covered yep but my point is that we're
always relying on people to somebody
stop paying their payments yep but then
I've got nothing to anyway to start with
I know you got a plan that me I'm just
trying to do excuses when are you gonna
stop making excuses and start taking
some risk but then you'll have something
to lose then too much to lose right now
is the time my friends to go crazy make
some money and take some risks even the
bracelet is coming is that another
excuse no it's a fact everyone's scared
that's a good thing because that means
that there's more opportunity
people stopped buying properties now
because they can't make a profit in
future this is gonna be an interesting
viewing so this house is a landlord six
bedrooms he wants 3,600 pounds a month
it's in really nice condition big six
double bedrooms nice house I'm gonna see
if I can knock him down and get him to
agree for me to rent out the rooms and
split the profit
so if he says yes out of my first deal
in London but you're you can look out
for the YouTube documentary my name
Samuel leaves tell me Leeds yeah check
it out man let me out
be in touch peace out brother I'm gonna
give him I'm gonna give it back
oh boo driver like a hundred panttiere
it says it's got a limit of 13 pound 42
that's an annoyance wrong pays wrong for
teacher that well it's still why don't
Samuel Leeds I'm a property investor I
don't own any houses London all of my
houses are outside of London and
everyone tells me this London is really
hard learners really expensive it's
impossible to make money in London
starting with no money so we literally
just my laptop laptop bag no money just
basic essentials for travelling things
like that
I'm gonna see if I can secure a no money
down property deal so let's see what we
can do in London with no money without
any knowledge of the area let's go
she's absolutely insane I'm just leaving
now okay let's go but we haven't
actually got anywhere to go to